Jeff good morning congratulations on the
new job where do you want to start with
Kyler Murray I want to start first by by
correcting the record here if I may for
a second dan less we not forget that the
Browns drafted Johnny Manziel because a
homeless man told Jimmy Haslem the owner
there that it was the right thing to do
okay so clearly you can be like Jerry
Jones listen to your personnel people
and take Zach Martin or you can be like
Jimmy Haslam let's do a random homeless
guy and end up with Johnny Manziel is
when do we know I'm not like the bitter
Cleveland's like a fan or anything like
that either not at all no I'm not
waiting for a championship or anything
when do we find out what Kyler Murray's
true intentions are going to be you know
I think and I ran this by a couple of
sources in the last few days I think
it's going to be within the next two to
three weeks or so and here's my
rationale behind that that gives the A's
some time to put together an offer
that's going to be financially
incentivizing for Kyler Murray to pass
up on football that also and the reason
it's this close as opposed to February
15th when he's due to report to Oakland
A's camp what that does is that allows
him to get into either shape if he's
going to be going to the NFL Scouting
Combine that starts February 26 he needs
to be trading for football and if he's
going to spring training he needs to be
training for baseball and I understand
that that to the layman to me to you to
everyone else out there that training
seems like training you go to the gym
you lift weights you run you do various
things but there are there are elements
of training especially when you're going
to something like the combine that is
just so specialized that you need to
focus on and a month lead time is about
right for a guy who's already as as fit
and athletic as Kyler Murray so I don't
know if it's gonna be by February 1st
but I think it's gonna be close to that
time does Kyler Moreno
sort of where he stands what is great is
as a football player having Scott Boras
as his agent who's a baseball guy does
that help her hurt you know trying to
figure out where Kyler Murray stands as
a first or second-round draft pick well
I think if Kyler Murray ends up being a
football player he's going to get a
football age and Scott Boras has never
represented football players in his life
and pride in being a baseball only guy
so I I don't think that is going to
factor into it what Scott Boras is doing
though is if there's a very interesting
dynamic going on right now and that is
normally the agent club relationship is
adversarial because the agent is trying
to get the most money and the team is
trying to pay the least money and
they're going to eventually negotiate
and find a place in the middle in this
case Billy Beane and Scott Boras his
interests are perfectly aligned both
both of them want Kyler Murray to play
baseball and both of them are trying to
work together to keep him playing
baseball because Scott Boras believes
that Kyler Murray can be a superstar
baseball player and Billy Beane believes
that Kyler Murray can be a superstar
baseball player and I think that if you
talk with other evaluators that might be
a bit of a stretch
some guys see his ceiling more like
Jackie Bradley jr. as opposed to a
Mookie Betts type and I you know the
fact though that we have as many players
in baseball who are Kyler Murray size
and have shown themselves to be
incredible you know Willie Mays 5 foot
10 Hank Aaron 5 foot 10 Tyler Murray is
not out of place in baseball in football
Kyler Murray is either an incredible
freak who has overcome limitations that
only one guy in modern football history
and thats Doug Flutie has done or he's
not going to be successful talking to
Jeff Passan ESPN senior baseball insider
are the A's the wrong team for Kyler
Murray in what regard
they're cheap
you know they don't spend they're not on
the baseball landscape even if they make
the playoffs like they're they're just
sort of a benign franchise could they I
wonder if Tyler Murray if his rights
were owned by somebody else would it be
like the dollars yeah if the Dodgers are
the Yankees or a marquee team did here's
the reason why I don't think it makes a
difference because the Dodgers and the
Yankees have bad minor-league places to
like you're gonna need to go to the
minor leagues no matter what inter Tyler
Murray and you might start in low a you
might start in high a the A's have him
ticketed for Stockton California right
now the colleague you know it's I'm glad
it's still early on the west coast
hopefully uh there are only a few people
listening the colleague is just a
desolate awful place and and so to start
your career there when you could be
playing in front of 80,000 people in NFL
stadiums on every Sunday like that is is
ultimately what I wonder if it drives
Kyle armories decision yeah and is the
is the prospect of being in podunk
cities in stadiums playing in front of a
couple thousand apathetic fans and I
really going to get the competitive
juices flowing in him I think he's got a
taste of stardom he's played in front of
big crowds his entire football career
from high school on and I think it's
hard to sort of say do you know that
spotlight hey I'll be back in a couple
of years to shine again I just get the
feeling he loves football
he's got leverage here but if I'm if I'm
the A's all I want to know is his Kyler
just answered this question what do you
love more baseball or football because
if he's not sure I I move on I I can't I
can't be invited here's here's the thing
that Dan let me let me throw this out to
you I talked with drew Hansen last we
drew Henson last week and it was a
really interesting conversation because
the way he put it is if you've grown up
your whole life loving two things like
what we were as a society into this
sport
monogamy and and we see it with our kids
I see it all the time I have an 11 year
old and and people ask what sport does
he play I'm like he plays sports plural
he plays baseball plays basketball he
plays you know he runs he does as much
as you can because I'm trying to create
a love of sports for him in Kyler's
Murray I think is allowed to love
football and baseball and and the idea
that he's being forced to choose here it
sucks for him it's not it's not an easy
enough decision I think for them to go
to him and say which do you love more
and for him to be able to answer like
that because there are just so many
factors at play here whether it's money
whether it's Fame whether it's parental
pressure there are all kinds of things
and I do not I I in so many ways envy
Kyler Murray but having to make a
decision like that dad at 21 years old
when you don't know anything about the
world like a you know drew Henson almost
20 years later still has regrets over
his choice and it's not regrets that he
signed with the New York Yankees and and
gave up football all together but he
wanted to go back to Michigan for his
senior year and feels like he really
should have done that your gut feeling
is going to be what for Kyler Murray my
gut feeling is football I think the
Oakland A's are going to go absolutely
all out I think they're going to make
him a blow you away offer and I think
it's gonna be a lot closer than it
should be but QB one is QB one man and
if you're a kid from Texas that is all
you need to hear when you've got a
first-round grade on you Jeff great
stuff is always congrats on the new gig
at the mothership and we'll be keeping
an eye on what you report thank you Dad
great coming on and appreciate you
having me Jeff Passan ESPN senior
baseball writer for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
you
[Music]